uh-oh
best game of all time what game has such
amazing gameplay a story so deep and
complex that few people can actually
understand it I'm talking of course
about bayonetta but anyone who plays it
for the story or the gameplay it's
clearly lying I think this is gonna be
an awesome let's play it's been a while
since we did an older game this is a
game that I'm really really excited
about I can't wait to play this and
hopefully by the end of it March 10 will
still stay with me I should warn you
though
don't flag this video please the game is
very confusing and start but I think
once we get going it'll be very very
interesting
daily let's play so if you enjoy well
please do leave a like I really
appreciate it it helps out a lot and
here you go all right fine
get closer yeah [ __ ] purple let's get
right into the boobs in a universe of
light and dark where perception is
reality where is the ass and the titties
what is the Sailor Moon so I don't know
anything about the stories I'm gonna try
my best to oh my god [ __ ] the story geo
Oh gets better this is the greatest
story of all time oh my god it never
ends what the [ __ ] is that
that was a [ __ ] cow bulge oh my god
edit that out I'm sorry knows too much
Jesus Christ I did not expect that oh my
god I get to play it right away yeah I
love win the game suit oh my god I'm
naked best game oh there's a story going
on the background a struggle caused the
Trinity of realities to be I could not
care less honestly I'm sorry I just
crimson ass I don't know what's going on
but I love it and this is the greatest
game of all time Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ] how can the Wii U perform holy [ __ ]
nice ass shot I appreciate that thank
you very much okay
and now the game turned into a mecca of
course Oh what the [ __ ] is going on
[ __ ] flying [ __ ] look at this I don't
know oh my god [ __ ] happens all the time
how can you keep up with this Jesus what
this book is that a [ __ ] umbrella
I guess just play an umbrella awesome
Bayonetta do something she did it oh my
god more sexy ladies [ __ ] yes it's the
most Japanese sound effect of all oh my
god sage cheeky oh my god she's British
that's hot as balls myself please don't
leave me oh my god
we're gonna scratch your beautiful face
I think God oh that's a great shot oh my
god who is it what oh I wish my eyes
could do that can we do that effect was
I cool thank you pressing day okay it
takes place in 2016 that's cool
of course he puts on the monocle and
that gives him strength so question is
just go with it you know that's the
first rule of Bayonetta movie oh my god
what the [ __ ] it's good hahaha that guy
literally look like a pig you can tell
this game is Japanese just by looking at
the style or maybe this giant Sega logo
should be kind of a giveaway Nintendo as
well what the hell is this guy oh my god
hey there she is you know what I need
some heels without guns you don't mind
if we make a quick stop do you do you
know what day's coming up here I was
shopping
- real business then you show up and
turn me into a damn quarter
seriously Bayonetta you still haven't
paid me back for the car hey whoa down
is this any way to speak to an old
friend I love her accent besides I did
that job food if it's right dad do I
really have to tell everyone how you
grabbed onto my legs sobbing like a
schoolboy
I'd do that I'd volunteer hey this is
why I can't have good things you some
piece of work you know that you weren't
already lined up to go to inferno
oh my well on your way with all the [ __ ]
you pull dressing up like a nun do so
you could off some angels and kick the
underworld happy hey I'm talking to you
son a lot of math to [ __ ] if it's better
getting tormented for eternity whatever
circle with infernal you witches go cool
that's not how you walk by the way the
body
forget about it oh hey what the [ __ ] you
wasting your time trying to send some
schmutz off to the afterlife for long
done and done hey let's go home hey wait
a sec it I ain't done here how is he
carrying all those magazines before I'm
gonna be the biggest month in the city
it's making me anxious as [ __ ] who came
to fetch my damn real funny I know
better than to tell you a damn thing
I'll never hear the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god Jason
of course she caught all of them no
problem you always know how to make an
entrance job and they just throw them
rare sight to see you in the city just
heard something oh my
cereza you haven't felt anything strange
recently
oh my god I think their periods are
synced I still haven't quite figured out
how a broke fumbling wiseguy managed to
turn himself into a semi respectable
family
forget up forget a baddie Serratia [ __ ]
you're about as sweet as my Nonna's
grandpa I know that
so which with amnesia goes around
calling herself a weapon and it turns
out she really got stuck with a kid's
nickname that shit's rich I tell you
when at a kid's knee our friends in
Paradiso are far too quiet I'm sure
you've noticed mm-hmm now make out
please
but they aren't the only ones pray tell
our friends down south seem to be a bit
upset as well they're definitely talking
about their vaginas I'm sorry oh you saw
this shadow today city police have
closed off roads to prepare for the
Macedon lots of merrymakers expected to
take in this year's festivities set to
be headlined by olive oil from the
military's aerial acrobatics
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the Platinum star that what crap
we need to hurry up and get Ed and
Edna's presents I'm gonna get it
I've got so elegant
we'll talk later I'll see you back home
they both have British X get to pick up
the things for the party
why are they in New York I don't
understand I have so many questions
oh my god so Japan why couldn't she just
drive off
okay what's up with the Jets what's the
matter with you what's the matter a jet
I want a toy jet you know the kind with
wings lies in the sky no I'm not buying
any damned angels yellow blue I don't
care what color they are I learned my
lesson with those bastards you hear me
just normal damn jet please
what is his monologue nothings flying in
the air right now
the guy's just thinking what the [ __ ]
I'm not paid for this this guy's my
mentor what
he got his gentle right
oh my god jimena I try to avoid doing
this in my Sunday best oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is kick it
oh and now it's lice
[Music]
we're steering it I don't understand
oh my god it's just like the Sailor Moon
thing it's just like the Sailor Moon
thing
oh my god
oh my god Jesus Oh
[Music]
best game of all time Oh
I can't I can't played it I can oh it
keeps happening
I'm crying it's so beautiful
[Music]
oh my god yes
I don't know I'm not even playing and
I'm totally fine with it
that was the best cutscene of my life
I'm gonna regret this video I know it it
plays beautifully I'm [ __ ] love it
just punch it see ya butterfly wings
yeah [ __ ] off wow oh my god
I love the music
this is why I never bought it safe
did it crack did it crack somewhere all
that damn it the guns bro damn it gosh
damn it cat oh my god what is happening
rattle turn oh my god
holiday cheer oh it's that ro who I
think it is so what you mom
oh my god yes it's black Santa he takes
the kids presents instead of [ __ ]
there was some funny I'm sorry
[ __ ] bad-ass how did he start the car
forget about it
he drives the boss
but why not
santa claus got his new gun [ __ ] yeah
oh she's gonna do the transform again
please ah damn it
she got [ __ ] runs under heels oh my
god [ __ ] yes that's literally my face of
playing this entire game
feudal you would have fun oh my god this
game is ridiculous
I [ __ ] mama oh alright I can be nutty
Oh
I'm naked and okay so I use my clothes
to perform attacks chief genius only
Japan would Google back wouldn't they oh
here we go bye bye [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah
never been this happy in my life I'm not
joking this is like literally Christmas
for me that's a kid
oh my god
[ __ ] yeah
it's so [ __ ] bad-ass Jesus
oh she's back
I don't know how to keep up with this
it's so much [ __ ] happening all the
[ __ ] time
of course the dragon would wait awaiting
that even come from I know I'm not good
at the game but I'll get better all
right don't worry about Oh slap that ass
torture attack Oh slap that ass oh yeah
slap that face oh yes
get in there slap that ass yeah that's
right and then booty that's what I'm
talking about
they keep coming
what is that Oh God what just happened
oh [ __ ] we go now we're going down Jesus
I got a jump ok
butterfly jam badass oh we got a silver
that was [ __ ] beautiful
ok Jesus Christ Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ Jesus great I got it gonna end
the first part there if we keep this
going I would really appreciate your
support if you leave a comment and I'm
like let me know if you want more I
would love to play more of this
it's a [ __ ] blast this is so my type
of game and hopefully further along we
get into the story and all that stuff so
let me know if you want more I like I
said I would love to do it and I'll make
the episodes longer as we go I like to
start off the first one a little shorter
that's it for me for now though thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed and as always stay awesome rest
oh my god oh my god coming down
I totally read
Oh God
[Music]